it is reported on the authority of sa
Jama that the prophet of Allah when
asked about the women and children yes
of the Poli yeah being
killed during the night raid during what
being killed during the night raid yeah
during the night raid said they are of
them okay so first so so I know you're
going to go to 1 Samuel 15 no no no I'm
going to
goated it so this firstly let's no no
hold on hold brother respectful
conversation in so what I what I think
is important is we don't make it out we
don't like in in Islam we don't what uh
what I'm saying is what what what we
want to do is not make it out as if in
Islam there is no killing there's no
command of kill there's no commandment
blooded okay no no I ask about Bloodshed
first no no you should be the last
person blood shed no no wait wait wait I
mean I mean the Old Testament just
Bloodshed just killing babies day and
night step by step no no no to correct
you because it says they are of them
talking about of them no problem first
commanded Muslim
commanded let let me let me let me let
me so this which
is the compan came to him he said
because there not explain it cuz you
know in order for you to understand let
me give you some nice benefit yeah it's
not like your even maybe with the Bible
as well sometimes you know you got P
Here There and understand everything
yeah so sometimes the the narrators
doesn't narrate everything they narrate
some of it the other the other some of
it and the they got all the the
narrations and theyy to harmonize it
harmonize it and bring all together for
example J comes to me he said the
brother in the park said he was going to
the market another brother said yeah in
the market he this and that so and other
brother bringing all the information to
say what J said word for word anyway so
this they came to him they say oh
messenger Allah when we do night raid
against these Believers sometimes
we sometimes we kill the
children said is from them what does
mean you cannot Escape it because it's
night time then Prophet Muhammad
wasallam clearly said do not kill
children and woman IMI which is a
student of the companions said this
Hadith clearly abgate that narration
that's why the score is mentioned now if
the disbelievers are you saying there's
error errors in the Hadith no there's
not errors no if a if brother told me
was in the market but this is children
being killed no no no no no he said but
Muhammed didn't
say hold brother brother respect I I
like you
brother Muhammad didn't say no no no no
no why did you do that to the children
why did there was no with respect no
compassion see another Nation PUK them
he rebuked them okay I'll show you thei
okay firstly no first listen this one
the the pagans they used to hide behind
children okay you got evidence yeah
because there's no war you're saying and
at night yes they behind children night
time sometimes dark they cannot see them
okay explained I think you should be as
shame of yourself obviously you know
what okay that's okay that's said go
because you know
for said go okay for the sake argument
here he said it okay for the S he never
said it yeah there's not ntion clearly
said don't kill children and
women here okay and compare this
narration with the narration go and
Slaughter the babies in the Bible in the
Quran in the
Quran Quan them or a in the monastery
that the people of the scriptures or
even take down a says the polytheists
are the worst of creatures it is it is
rational and reasonable to believe that
the children who are of the worst of
creatures should die this way no no said
the children no said the children of the
Poli because children are born as a
Muslim okay so he said every child is
born as a Muslim okay that's why saw the
children of the Poli with ibraim
teaching them are you saying are you
saying after them Muhammad's children
are born of
the children are born said children are
born they believe in the Creator believe
in God generally speaking yes that's why
step by step so this Hadi I think you've
been very deceptive to try toze respect
I tell you I tell you I tell you I tell
you what I clarified you they came to at
evidence said clarify
it let's see the
eving like you said that they were
hiding behind wait wait don't okay doep
because because
why
okay we don't condone killing in the
Bible we don't condone so we go kill
babies good or bad in the Newen no no
I'm asking you when God said kill the
babies was that good or bad you cond it
or cond still finding the verse I'll
just in the New Testament there is no
evidence no evidence that Jesus ordered
killings in fact you're diverting no no
you're diting diting you know he and
brother so Peter took his sword as they
were arresting Jesus and he struck the
guard what did Jesus say put away your
sword he that dies by the sword he that
lives by the sword will die by The Sword
in fact what did Jesus do he healed he
healed his
air Jesus was against capital punishment
because he was the Fulfillment of the
levitical law Muslim watch how
explicitly don't kill children all right
no we're talking about no no no wa wa
don't kill children I'm going to bring
theing the really explicitly because
this one no there's no contradiction
because this one as mentioned you cannot
Escape them that's what I mean mean you
can escape them they mix with them okay
you can escape them
then at night look even logically
speaking now if I go War at night that
time there was no light nothing you have
enemies they send it Arrow at you yes
how are you going to do you say or you
going to fight back you're going to
fight back correct if you're going to
fight back there have the children then
so said which as mentioned you canot
escape them how do we understand that
because we have a clear Hadith
explicitly Prophet muhamad said it's
narrated by that a woman was found
killed in one of these battles so the
messenger brother you know I'm speaking
speak next to my you can go there sorry
so it is narrated
that woman was found killed in one of
these battles so the messenger of Allah
forbade the king of woman and
children who children that's one thing
the other thing I want to mention you
you I could say Jesus said suffer not
the CH suffer not no no no no no wait
step is like step by step Jes Jesus in
the Old Testament was Jesus God I'm
asking you look otherwise I'm going to
walk away cuz I don't like in time you
mention you said you have me finish you
have me finish no you miss other points
you mentioned to the audience here you
said Jesus never order the king of
children
correct I didn't say
that I said I said it was part of an
event no no no no no no just now when I
was looking for it I think you you're
going to hear it maybe you did say you
said J
never no only say part of events there's
no need for me to Li okay D order K of
children he didn't order the killing but
what it was was it was it was basically
the amalekites were killing the the the
Jewish people for 400 years why do
people not realize this they were
killing them all over the place they
were doing genocide to the Jewish people
and basically as they were leaving Egypt
they were ambushed by the amalekites in
fact we even know Hamman in the Book of
Esther descended from the amalekites and
still tried to kill and commit a
genocide to the Jewish people that's why
God said to King sa okay that yes as
part of an event what was my question I
know what was my question I'm getting no
what was my question I know you're
saying did he order killing he said no
he didn't no I'm saying to you that it's
part of an event I'm not asking part of
events of course event okay kill event
are you saying it applies today no no no
wait step by step by step because you're
going back to the old brother step step
by step yeah what's your
name come on go there I can't that dis
course she can okay non head no no
godhead I'm
anyway no no listen listen list I don't
you're saying your passord name goodhead
no you're saying your name sham but your
passord good I trust your I trust what
you no no I show my ID I trust you I
trust I
TR the ministry no problem anyway I mean
no problem problem no anyway listen
carefully my question was to you did
Jesus order the killing of children
that's was my question I'm going to ask
you again the I'm asking is it event or
it was not event everything is wedding
is Event Event me something happening
that's what it means event something
like like an incident like something you
know event okay anyway when the question
did Jesus order many times let me finish
let me finish let me finish let me
finish let me finish let me finish did
Jesus order the king of children many
times God allowed for justice to WIP
out playing with
a he ordered he okay I show
you no no wait wait wait wait wait wait
you see we have to be honest to
ourselves because why clearly not honest
you know why because allowing is
different than ordering because God
controls everything God allows you to
speak wait wait wait wait
wait wa wait wait second person by
person Christian
christianen
Care let me finish let me finish let me
let me finish let me finish let me
finish let me finish let me finish let
me finish okay you you said you said
allowing allowing you speaking now God
allowing you to speak but you speaking
that every action that we take God is
allowing us to do it because go go God
control everything God can stop you any
time he wants by taking your life
correct so my question to you again did
Jesus order many times in the Bible
killing babies and children
infants this is not okay I'm going to
show you yes he did no so so ordered
many times king of babies and in the Old
Testament I I will
challenge God pronounced judgment and
children were killed so did he order it
you pronounce judgment no no it's a
commandment command that's why I'm going
to conclude with this you can see not
Jud I'm going to show you I'm going to
show
you they don't like the word order watch
this and they're going to say is shami
being intellectually honest I think it's
you he's more deserving of being asked
that question he's making it out making
it out AB it's a it's a A continuing
command and listen listen listen it's
continue command not for you Christians
for the Jewish who believe in the Old
Testament okay but now my question is I
would even dis I disagree with that yeah
no no but even I question where it was
yeah did Jesus order many times in the
Old Testament KY of the babies and
children yes or no did he because in the
Bible yes he did did he pronounce
judgment command pronounce judgment your
words got the word command the word
order is not in there I'll show you is
okay what you see the Commandments of
what you see step by step we can acest
just for the sake of argument pronounce
judgment just go there just for the sake
of argument you see even judgment is a
command yeah of course that's what I'm
saying a command he thinks he's escaping
it no a command is where it says you're
not solicit I'm going to show you the
command you say Stone someone no
stepic diging digressing digressing
digressing listen listen listen listen
Samuel said to Saul God anoints you to
do what he anoint him to do what yeah to
pronounce judgment so he chose him then
he time to go go to Go and Kill is it
commandment or not okay it's judgment
take care of yourself yeah gam
take
take he says that these people they play
with
slogans they play with
words me me let me
round yeah yeah other brothers our ceras
there any our ceras Muslim ceras there
see
May there ceras there the Muslim
my dear brothers and sisters ladies and
gentlemen as a Muslim when we come speak
Muslims when we come speak in corner we
not here for entertainment okay we're
not here just to speak for the sake of
speaking we want to have a conversation
if I notice a person is been dishonest
intellectually dishonest there's no need
to carry with him I was asking him
clearly and simply simply and clearly
did Jesus in the old test Commander the
king of babies and children many times
he he started playing around it's
allowing guess what in the Old Testament
says Go and Kill God said go and kill
command there's a command still trying
to play around so you cannot speak to
him because this person is not open to
the truth okay he tried to use a Hadith
which is the discuss this Hadith about
in the war if the enemies attacking the
Muslims then the enemies run run back to
their Villages and they have children in
the front to protect them are the
Muslims allowed to uh uh uh uh shoot or
uh fire arrow fire the the arrows other
than arrows our time bullet and so on at
the the target is the enemies not the
children but because they cannot Escape
children the children have to die with
them some said you cannot do it based
upon thei of prophet Muhammad said do
not kill woman and children as for
the explained it he said said you cannot
escape the meaning because at Night
Never commanded he never commanded then
we have a clearth said don't do it okay
clear that's the outcome of following
unth he left the clear Hadith the clear
verses what he started doing looking for
unclear Hadith and clear verses and this
the way of the people of the book even
with their own Bible they go they leave
clear verses or clear passages and they
go to un clear passages to justify their
misguidance alhamd Allah guide him but
even you know
that is clear to you man bless you